Traduttore: TEDx Milano Translators
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Il primo organo che si vede
è il cuore, non è il cervello.
Io non me l'aspettavo.
Forse è una cosa che ci dimentichiamo,
nel corso della vita.
Ma questa è l'ecografia al terzo mese.
Al quinto mese,
quella che si chiama la morfologica,
la poesia è già finita.
L'ecografista si muove su un'immagine
che tu non capisci, e dice:
"E il cervelletto?
Vediamo se c'è. Sì, c'è il cervelletto.
E il femore?
Vediamo se è lungo il giusto.
Sì, è lungo il giusto."
E io mi dico: "Come il cervelletto?
Ma perché non dovrebbe
esserci, il cervelletto?
E poi a cosa serve, se non ci fosse?
E il femore quanto deve essere lungo?"
E lui va avanti, ormai è molto
più avanti l'elenco degli organi.
Ecco, si nasce così.
Misurati, calibrati, verificati
rispetto a dei parametri standard attesi.
Si nasce già con un voto,
cioè l'indice di Apgar alla nascita.
È una sintesi di parametri di salute
che in qualche modo dice,
in decimi, come i voti a scuola,
quanto è sano tuo figlio dal minuto zero.
E così - e questo è solo il trailer.
Le ecografie che fai sono solo il trailer
di un film che farai, che vedrai dopo.
Perché, appena nasce,
devi misurare di quanti grammi
cresce ogni settimana.
E sono 30, 40, 50, non di più.
E tuo figlio non sta fermo.
E misuralo tu, su una bilancia,
un bambino che si muove.
E se sono 40-50,
è difficile perché oscilla.
E, se sono di meno, ti viene il panico
perché forse non mangia abbastanza,
non hai il latte che serve.
E poi deve crescere di tot centimetri,
e c'è una curva che vedi,
ogni volta che vai dal pediatra,
ed è la curva di crescita
della popolazione media.
E tuo figlio è lì che balla
sopra, sotto, durante.
E se è sopra, c'è l'orgoglio di papà
e di mamma: "Mio figlio è sopra la media".
E se è sotto no, taci:
c'è un po' più la vergogna.
Finché ad un certo punto può darsi
che scivoli al decimo percentile.
Allora lì c'è il panico.
C'è il panico del fatto che forse
devi fare le cure ormonali,
forse non sta crescendo come dovrebbe.
Forse qualcosa non va -
ma il fatto è che tu,
tuo figlio, non lo guardi.
Lo controlli, che è molto diverso.
(Musica)
Allora,
con questa ansia da genitore
addosso, fai tutto il possibile.
Allora giostrine, palestrine,
stimoli di ogni tipo.
Come se la natura non bastasse,
come se non potesse fare il suo corso,
come se la realtà non fosse
abbastanza curiosa da osservare.
E vai a inseguire,
a cercare le cose "giuste".
Quindi leggi sulle scatole,
chiedi ai negozianti "la cosa giusta
per un bambino di tre anni",
anzi una bambina di tre anni.
Il libro giusto, la scatola giusta.
Ma tu non è che stai guardando lui o lei,
stai guardando la scatola.
E lo chiedi al negoziante,
che cosa prendere.
Perché hai già il mercato addosso,
perché il mercato ti assedia.
Il mercato è entrato in scena
il primo giorno,
almeno nella nostra esperienza.
Perché quando è nato Pietro,
accanto c'era già il pacco.
La cremina, la pomatina, la spazzolina.
Pietro era nato, ed era già
un nuovo consumatore.
E poi non ti molla:
il mercato, lo sanno bene
gli psicologi del marketing,
ha due linguaggi:
uno è quello che usa
coi bambini, con i ragazzi,
ed è un linguaggio che tu
non capisci completamente,
perché è fatto di colori accesi,
di forme - studiate, ovviamente.
E poi di personaggi, che sono
quelli dei cartoni e dei film,
che ad un certo punto sono dappertutto.
Sono sui tovaglioli,
nei piattini dei compleanni,
stampate sulle torte,
sugli zainetti, i quaderni, i diari.
Sono ovunque.
Tanto che li trovi senza un problema.
E ti sembra che tuo figlio li vuole:
ma non li vuole lui.
Lui, in quel momento, non sta desiderando,
neanche sta facendo i capricci:
sta eseguendo un compito.
Perché è il mercato che desidera per lui.
Lui sta eseguendo quel compito.
E tu intanto sei impegnato in altro,
perché il messaggio per te è diverso,
il codice è diverso.
Il tuo codice è quello stampato
sulle istruzioni delle confezioni,
dove c'è scritto:
"Questa cosa è adatta per,
qui dentro ci sono le vitamine,
questo fa bene
per questo, per quell'altro.
Perché gli psicologi
del marketing lo sanno,
che tu devi sentirti un bravo genitore.
Ed è questo il messaggio che ti è rivolto.
(Suono della campanella)
In questo assedio normativo,
la scuola ci mette del suo.
Quando Pietro è entrato
alla scuola materna
eravamo un po' in ritardo,
rispetto all'inserimento.
Qualche giorno dopo arriviamo,
e il gruppo è già formato:
i bambini stanno cantando
con l'insegnante in coro una canzone,
con il libro delle canzoni
dell'insegnante.
Allora Pietro, per inserirsi, dice:
"Posso cantare
la canzone della montagna?".
E canta la sua canzone,
pensa che questo sia la chiave,
e si inventa questa canzone.
L'insegnante guarda il quaderno
e dice: "No, scusa.
Non c'è la canzone della montagna,
non la possiamo cantare".
Nella materna ci sono appese
tutte quelle sagome, già fatte,
che tu devi colorare dentro,
guai ad uscire fuori.
Usa i colori giusti.
Se usi i colori scuri, il viola e il nero,
poi l'insegnante ti dice:
"C'è qualcosa che non va?".
Margherita, sette anni,
ci chiede, a colazione:
"Ma quanti sono 60 secondi?"
E noi glielo facciamo vedere.
Margherita non ha l'orologio:
un bambino di sette anni
non deve, avere l'orologio.
Ma che cosa succederà?
Le chiediamo: "Perché
hai bisogno di saperlo?".
"Eh, domani c'è l'Invalsi",
Che va in scena in seconda elementare,
che è un test a tempo.
E da quel momento, per Margherita,
il tempo va al contrario.
Anziché scorrere com'è nella natura,
com'è nella sua vita,
va al contrario, come in fabbrica,
a lavoro, come qui.
E da lì le prende un'ansia tremenda.
Una sua compagna di classe
viene dallo Sri Lanka.
E allora si assenta qualche giorno
per andare nel paese
d'origine della famiglia.
Quando torna, l'insegnante chiede:
"Ma scusa, dove sei stata
in questi giorni?".
Lei dice: "Sono stata in Sri Lanka,
il paese dei miei genitori".
E l'insegnante le dice...
"Ah, bene. Adesso
mettiti in pari coi compiti".
Mettiti in pari coi compiti?!
Ma quell'insegnante
l'ha vista, quella bambina?
O ha sovrascritto su di lei
l'allieva che doveva essere?
Quel giorno, la lezione,
la doveva tenere quella bambina!
È questo che succede:
noi, in realtà, i bambini,
i ragazzi non li vediamo.
Cioè, li guardiamo non per quello
che sono, che fanno,
ma per quello che ancora non sono,
non fanno, non hanno.
Cioè sostanzialmente misuriamo
la loro distanza
fra la nostra aspettativa
e il nostro standard,
la nostra misura
e quello che sono, ma che non ci basta.
E la loro vita va avanti
fino a 16, 20 anni -
Quando incontro i ragazzi
con cui faccio ricerca, che intervisto,
con cui facciamo insieme le cose,
e loro mi dicono:
"Ma tutti questi test, queste verifiche,
queste prove, questi casting -
a parte che, in Italia, in vista di cosa?
Qual era il premio? Qual era
il traguardo di questa rincorsa?
E poi ti dicono: "Ma, senti,
io non so, in realtà, che cosa mi piace.
Ho sempre fatto quello che dovevo.
E poi non mi sento abbastanza.
Forse non sono adeguata.
Forse non ce la farò,
forse non riuscirò, non lo so.
Non so cosa scegliere,
ho paura del futuro".
Ma com'è possibile?
Nell'età della potenza,
dell'eros, del desiderio,
aver paura della realtà e del futuro?
Ma come abbiamo potuto portare
una generazione a quel punto?
Anziché convocarla nella realtà,
l'abbiamo tenuta in esilio, in cattività,
anziché dare compiti
di realtà e responsabilità.
Questo dico: è sostanzialmente una follia
che non possiamo più permetterci.
Per il semplice motivo
che ci stiamo dimenticando
che noi, quando emigravamo,
emigravamo ragazzi.
E l'intera famiglia scommetteva
sui ragazzi che partivano,
per ritrovare l'economia e la felicità.
Gli adulti scommettevano sui ragazzi.
Ci stiamo dimenticando che il Novecento
è stato fatto di idee, e di scoperte,
di giovani che avevano
fra i 20 e i 30 anni!
Einstein aveva 26 anni,
quando ha scritto l'articolo
famoso sulla relatività.
Quindi non era quel
vecchio bianco, coi baffoni.
No, era un giovane di 26 anni.
Ci stiamo dimenticando
che le grandi aziende degli anni 2000
sono state fatte da ragazzi
che avevano fra i 18 e 25 anni.
Questo non è il migliore
dei mondi possibili.
Forse ce lo dobbiamo dire.
E proprio perché non è
il migliore dei mondi possibili,
e lo dobbiamo raccontare così,
dobbiamo provare a trovare dei varchi
per fare entrare i ragazzi.
Assumerci il compito
del suo miglioramento.
È da lì che si entra:
perché se il mondo è saturo, museificato,
non entri, non c'è posto per te.
Ed è quello che sentono i ragazzi,
che non si sentono utili
perché non c'è posto.
Non sono previsti, è tutto già occupato.
Un po' come questo teatro.
E allora da dove entri,
se tutto è già predisposto,
è tutto già pronto?
Non solo: la realtà è cambiata
tantissimo, in questi anni.
E la mia base esperienziale
non conta nulla
rispetto a quella che ha,
e avrà, un ragazzo.
Io non sono la misura dei miei figli,
e gli adulti presenti non sono
la misura dei ragazzi presenti.
Parlo per me.
Io ho fatto un liceo
che è cambiato completamente,
un'università che è
cambiata completamente.
Ho fatto l'obiezione di coscienza
al servizio militare
facendo un servizio civile di 20 mesi.
Nulla di tutto questo esiste.
Ho cercato lavoro con le Pagine Gialle!
(Risate)
Sono andato a guardare
"Società di ricerca",
ho mandato sei lettere
e ho trovato lavoro.
Potrò mai dire questo, ad un ragazzo?
Ho parlato una lingua,
ho vissuto in una città,
ho fatto un solo mestiere.
Anche questa, probabilmente,
non è più la misura, evidentemente,
dei ragazzi che ho di fronte.
Credo che questa generazione
che abbiamo di fronte,
e molti sono presenti,
non debbano essere formati come allievi
che devono eseguire dei compiti prescritti
perché c'è un manuale
che valeva ieri e vale oggi.
Devono essere formati come pionieri,
e formarsi come pionieri
è del tutto diverso.
Vuol dire che devi spostare
la frontiera della conoscenza.
Vuol dire che devi studiare
e devi anche imparare a disimparare,
come diceva Gregory Bateson.
Quindi sostanzialmente,
a ricostruire continuamente le regole.
Vuol dire che devi
essere formato con domande.
Non allenato a rispondere
come succede a scuola.
E queste domande devono essere
domande legittime, non illegittime,
che son quelle che ci sono
a scuola e all'università.
Che sono quelle dove:
chi fa la domanda sa la risposta;
e chi risponde sa di dover dare
la risposta che è
nella testa di chi domanda.
Se sei allenato così,
non ti pensi portatore
di alcun sapere, di alcuna scoperta,
di alcuna possibilità
di ingresso nella realtà.
Perché tutto è già scritto e già fatto.
Un giorno siamo al mare.
Pietro ha 10, 11 anni e mi dice:
"Papà, voglio diventare ricco".
Noi non siamo ricchi.
E io non so come prenderla
e mi viene in mente questo:
"Bello, così può essere generoso".
E lui mi dice: "No, non intendevo questo".
(Risate)
E allora cerco di riprenderla
in un altro modo, e dico:
"Ok, Pietro.
Allora, per diventare ricco,
devi trovare qualcosa
che sia la soluzione
a un problema comune.
una risposta che risponde,
in qualche modo,
a un'esigenza collettiva.
E quindi, forse, può avere successo".
Lui si guarda attorno e dice:
"Potremmo rendere potabile
quest'acqua, l'acqua del mare".
C'eravamo.
Questa è la sfida di cui parlo.
Cercare di assumersi compiti di realtà,
qualcosa che davvero urge da fuori,
e provare a cercare
soluzioni con i ragazzi.
Questo faccio:
gruppi interdisciplinari,
dove metto insieme
il pensiero divergente dei bambini,
l'energia dei ragazzi,
la maturità degli adulti.
E insieme re-immaginiamo quartieri,
biblioteche, scuole,
per capire cosa si può fare.
Spegniamo la luce.
Rompiamo il ricatto del presente,
perché è reale molto più della realtà.
Il presente non è
il repertorio del possibile.
E immaginiamo cos'altro
si può fare in un luogo.
In un lavoro che ho appena fatto,
ho chiesto loro addirittura questo:
"Sentite, abbiamo
i negozianti, i residenti.
A voi chiedo di fare gli alberi.
Fatevi portavoce della natura.
Perché ci serve capire,
qualunque cosa faremo in questo quartiere,
ci serve avere l'orizzonte
lungo della natura,
e siete gli unici
che possono incarnare la natura."
E loro lo fanno, e sono contentissimi -
di questo sto parlando.
Noi, in realtà, questa cosa
di mettersi insieme
e di collaborare insieme
la facciamo, in Italia:
ma la facciamo una sola volta,
quando ci sono le grandi emergenze,
quando ci sono i terremoti, le alluvioni.
Quando avvengono quelle cose,
siamo uno accanto all'altro.
E non ci chiediamo "chi è quello lì",
non è che lo misuriamo rispetto a quello -
Abbiamo un compito di realtà urgente,
e lo facciamo assieme.
E funziona.
In quelle circostanze spesso
guardiamo i ragazzi
e li chiamiamo, il giorno dopo,
gli "Angeli del Fango".
Ci accorgiamo di loro
solo in quella circostanza.
E loro non sono molto contenti.
E hanno ragione.
Ecco, di questo parlo:
di compiti di realtà.
In fondo è fare quello
che Hannah Arendt chiamava politica.
La politica non è occuparci
gli uni degli altri,
ma occuparci insieme,
del mondo, ogni giorno.
Grazie.
(Applausi)